Adele just finished a hundred seven  shows in 10 months and declare she's now  off to have another baby the singer  closed out the north american leg of her  tour in phoenix arizona on monday night  and after her performance and now she  would be taking a long break from music  before exiting the stage she said quote  I'll see you on the other side in a  couple of years I'll be back you won't  be able to get rid of me I'm going to  have another baby interestingly she  recently told Vanity Fair that son  Angela would likely be her only child  the last time Adele took a hiatus was  between album releases in 2011 and 2015  to focus on her son who is now four  years old he welcomed his mom back home  from tour with a sign that read mummy  you did it